coucou les chasseurs on a décidé de vous
faire visiter l'un des endroits les plus
hantés du monde l'histoire de ces lieux
est absolument incroyable et je peux
vous assurer que vous sentez leur
présence autour de vous allez pense même
pas
combien de temps qu'il est là dedans
[Musique]
ça doit être maman
je dois retourner chez nous je veux
savoir ce qui s'est passé
mais il faut que j'aille au parc
[Musique]
c'est interdit d'y rentrer
la nuit des lumières c'est le nom que
les gens du village ont donné à la nuit
ou tes parents ont disparu
[Musique]
je suis sûr de ce que j'ai vu je t'avais
dit que ton père était dans la maison la
malédiction
c'est pas possible
c'est elle c'était ma mère c'était pas
ta mère c'est
[Musique]
le parc très clair ici on a affaire à
une force de l'au-delà ce sont les
lumières du parc qui provoque les
cauchemars
[Applaudissements]
non ça recommence
[Musique]
la fin de toute chose est le début d'une
autre